saber defenderse para dejar de tener
miedo en el noroeste de santiago maite
orsini es abogada y diputada feminista
del partido revolución democrática en
uno de los distritos de la capital hoy
participa en un taller de defensa
personal destinado a los jóvenes de este
barrio popular dando la lucha por que
las niñas de chile puedan caminar por la
calle sin miedo y
lamentablemente hasta que no podamos
construir una sociedad feminista en la
que eso sea natural tenemos que
entregarle a las mujeres y las niñas
herramientas para que se empoderen para
que sientan que pueden defenderse frente
a una agresión las participantes a
presión esta iniciativa ahora somos de
una organización social de cerro navia y
durante los ensayos cuando nos retiramos
hemos sufrido como violencia las calles
entonces creemos que una buena forma
aprenderá a la autodefensa como un
mecanismo para poder salir de
situaciones complejas y creemos que es
responsabilidad de todas aprender
también a cuidarnos y es por eso que
quisimos venir en grupo tanto a la
chiquilla
en el 2021 más de 40 chilenas fueron
víctimas mortales de la violencia
doméstica
maite quiere llevar a cabo iniciativas
concretas para proteger a sus
conciudadanos
[Aplausos]
hoy día lanzamos una propuesta que se
llama la comisaría de la mujer hay
experiencia comparada en países como
argentina brasil sudáfrica hacia lo más
lejos en donde hay estaciones de
policías especializadas que son
atendidas únicamente por carabineros que
buscan dar una atención integral a las
mujeres víctimas de violencia para que
no haya más revictimización
desconfianza violencia en las mismas
comisarías a la hora de denunciar una
agresión
en octubre de 2019 hubo un levantamiento
popular en chile a modo de protesta
contra las desigualdades sociales
estas manifestaciones desembocaron en la
elección de una asamblea constitucional
que respeta la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres
su objetivo es redactar una nueva
constitución más igualitaria muchas
feministas integran esta asamblea y
están decididas a repensar las bases
históricamente patriarcales del estado
chileno
nuestro gran objetivo como feministas es
crear una constitución feminista y eso
además nos impone una labor que va más
allá de la cantidad de mujeres que
componen un espacio y que tiene que ver
con las transformaciones profundas a
nivel estructural social político
económico y cultural
para eliminar las brechas entre hombres
y mujeres pero además las posiciones
jerárquicas que en la sociedad han
establecido también las diferencias que
se traducen en desigualdades sociales
entre hombres y mujeres pero también con
otros grupos históricamente excluidos
me va a caer
con chile la causa de las mujeres se
enfrenta actualmente con el auge de los
discursos conservadores a unas semanas
de la segunda vuelta de la elección
presidencial el candidato de extrema
derecha jose antonio kast está a las
puertas del poder las feministas temen
que esto sea un retroceso para la
igualdad de los géneros no estamos
convocando aquí para manifestarnos en
contra del avance de los discursos de
odio negacionistas de ultraderecha
neofascistas que empiezan a aparecer en
nuestro país y ser exaltados por los
medios de comunicación que responden a
los intereses de la élite conservadora y
empresarial y aquí queremos decir que
creemos que somos más somos una mayoría
quienes miramos hacia el futuro pensando
en un país de derechos de dignidad de
igualdad de libertad y libre de
violencia
obviamente y que niegue los derechos de
las personas
en esta manifestación el mensaje es
claro la construcción de un nuevo chile
no se hará sin las mujeres
estamos acá y que somos parte
fundamental de la construcción del
presente y futuro de nuestro país que
sin nosotras que sin feminismo que sin
plena igualdad y reconocimiento de las
diversidades no hay democracia es
posible de construir
el camino aún es largo para las
feministas chilenas pero a punta de
determinación ya han logrado modificar
profundamente el panorama político de su
país
y compañeros a seguir adelante hasta la
victoria siempre lo personal
[Aplausos]